[Music]
thank you
anyways what is this frog makes weird
noise
[Laughter]
I do want I want to watch the Nick Cage
thing yeah let's peep that in a moment I
didn't know frogs made that noise if
this is an awe video
I'm not hurting the frog in any way
whatsoever you see it's puffing up its
body he's like a balloon right now
yes I know but you have have you not
figured out that you've already been
captured
was that real yeah that frog just saw
Timothy challenge
[Laughter]
not play that [__] again that was crazy
where does he where does he have his
thumb bro
sort of going like this yeah yeah
you've already been captured captured
that noise tells me you're not hurting
that frog
oh bro busted on his head
cupcake frog I'm horny
[Music]
damn
about to go [__] a frog after this
[Laughter]
that's every that's every [__] turn
that [__] into a prince yeah yeah yeah
every gen Z dude watching that [__]
[Laughter]
cool like that
like that damn I didn't know the Frog
was chill like that dude imagine
[__] a frog yeah
sorry sorry no imagine like at night you
know you hear frogs if it was just that
oh yeah
[Music]
that would be kind of awesome I'd be
sick
be so hot
you're gone [__] yeah almost there I'm
gonna [__] a frog after this
all right what's bear gets hit by car
all right then then we'll go to Nick
Cage I swear man hits bear with a car
fast yes I'm gonna go home and smoke a
[__] huge
oh my God I just hit the [__] out of a
[__] bear
are you serious oh my God yo I'm gonna
go home and [__] a fat [__] frog
after that oh [__] I gotta get off the
phone I'll talk to you soon
the sequence the sequence I have I'm
about to smoke a fat [__] bear
[Laughter]
yes I'm gonna go home and smoke a
[__] huge [__] oh my God
oh my God
Doug his voice
oh my God that's a Vine bro
oh my God
oh my God I just hit the [__] out of a
[__] bear
is he all right he runs away oh my God
okay so we're
here
[Music]
yo are you good
yo it's cocaine man
damn it dude bro smoke a fat [__]
[__] is it a bear
Jordan Peterson dude it just hit a beer
damn that's that was good what all right
Nick Cage oh wait wait go to the deer
one before we move on yeah from animals
the duels this one this one isn't as
um
so
oh this yeah I've seen this so sick
super tough
that's the deer that's coming to find us
yeah
you know what I'm saying if you have
that's like the Revenge deer yeah if you
haven't seen this it's a deer and it's
carrying around the head of another deer
that it like ripped off like assuming
they did like the deer horn battle thing
yeah and he won and now is just carrying
around the decapitated head of the other
ones that stuck to his antlers
yeah again another a24 Motif right here
you just see this thing walking through
ice and just
yeah yeah
and you're staring at it and then it
comes for you
it's coming for us for how many jokes
we've made yeah
I can't wait for this to be on like some
accounts like you see this
in the animal kingdom there are no
participation trophies yeah there are
only real trophies yeah yeah
dude that's subscribe to my class to
learn how to make money municipal.com
[Laughter]
imagine imagine we walk outside in that
deer
is standing outside with like
you know like Logan Paul's head yeah
hanging from one of its handlers yeah as
well as that deer's head yeah
yeah I'm more like another podcaster
yeah I'm running back inside and I'm
grabbing a [__] uh automatic drum
magazine shotgun and walk into the front
door oh
where is he just use your Bug Assault
yeah
you think you're gonna do anything to
that deer with a Bug Assault get it in
his eye
be licking his eyes it's all [__] up
that actually Logan Paul's head swinging
down like ew ew whoa nasty
yo what is this human car wash machine
all the way at the bottom
man I for sure thought this was gonna so
I'm just getting
[Music]
like
it's just it's awesome if you're
listening it's this what the [__] is the
point of this
it's literally what you'd expect in a
car wash it's just rotating brush that
can move vertically up and down
hey you could scrub your head I would
just stand over it and just hit the
button up and down yeah
yeah just rinsing your balls up and down
oh
I just can't wait till someone gets
caught up in one of these because they
have long hair
oh my gosh oh my God they're like bodies
foreign